okay let's go to our caller from the
eight one seven area code caller from
eight one seven tell us who you are and
where you're calling from eight one
seven go ahead
is it me yeah that's you oh sweet
yeah I've been calling in like probably
like four or five times before today's
the first time I've ever gotten on oh
goody thank you David yes my name is
jesse james Taurus I'm from Burleson
it's just south of Fort Worth Dallas
area a big fan of your show up in
Washington for like last like three
years thank you uh I actually have two
questions a is that okay sure that's as
long as neither one of them is
inordinately long no okay they're just
more like just your personal opinion
kind of thing okay okay first one is
regarding term limits yep okay we have
in the Constitution term limits for the
presidency you can only serve two full
terms and a half term if you fill in if
you're a vice president fill then right
so basically you cannot serve more than
ten years but we don't have a term
limits for the other two branches mm-hmm
do you think we should have term limits
and so how long should they be that's my
first questions but to partner I do
believe we should have term limits for
the House and Senate I've said this
before let me first make the strongest
argument I can against term limits I
think the strongest argument for letting
members of the House and Senate serve as
long as they keep getting reelected is
that you are allowing good people to
continue representing their constituents
right that would be the argument for
continuing by first I kind of know
argument to from like a lot of people I
say that we need to turn limits well
what if they're likable don't you want
to be in there for as long as they can
I'm like yeah but at the same time if
there's no other option like there are
some people who run unopposed because
know what's right so but let me if I can
just finish just so for the you seem to
know this but for the benefit of the
audience to know my position I think
that the arguments for term limits are
way stronger which is that we've got a
country of 340 million people you're
going to be able to get other good
people in you are eliminating a lot of
the motivations that exist to maintain
the status quo of our toxic politics
that that we have I believe that not
having career politicians would
hopefully allow us to cycle in people
from other areas of life other than just
mostly lawyers and and businesspeople so
I am in favor of term limits for the
House and Senate I don't have a strong
opinion as to
exactly how long those terms should be
personally I argue we should have 10
term limit for the house and a four term
limit to the Senate it's about 20 years
so twice long the executive branch which
makes sense I mean the founders wanted
the legislative branch to be the
dominant one and I argued this judicial
branch the Supreme Court and all of them
should be 20 years as well okay because
again they look like way too long for me
for House and Senate but for the Supreme
Court maybe that would make sense what
was your second question today okay this
one's regarding the territories not just
Puerto Rico but in general should
Washington DC and the five US
territories achieve statehood or are you
against them becoming States because I
personally argue they all should be
States already just because I mean why
not yeah I believe that they should not
maintain their current status I think
that the current status is sort of a
quagmire and it doesn't really benefit
anybody big picture so I would be open
to statehood I think that would be very
beneficial for the Democratic Party and
thus Republicans are going to oppose it
significantly I think the other
alternative would be independence of
course that's risky for some of the
territories the question of their salt
financial solubility as independent
states as independent countries is in
question but I don't like the current
status I would like the currents that
has changed I believe it's like a
hanging in the balance that's not really
good for anybody yeah I've always argued
that basically if you had a party of 56
people at an all-you-can-eat buffet
the island territories in DC would be
six people who only allowed one plate
they're not getting the full benefits
despite the fact they're part of the
party it's like oh everyone like the
other 50 states they all get to pay into
Social Security but then they get it
back and I like to get full benefits
like military benefits and all that they
have they like two representatives who
actually represent them yeah but the
territories in DC don't so it's like
what's the point
I argue they should just get full
statehood and just wear a good thing
only thing you brought it up
just one last quick thing I've done the
math I mean yeah some of the in part
sorry some of the territories would vote
Democrats but I mean I don't think it'd
be like full-on Democrat I think it may
be like a maybe two to one vote but like
they'd all have like a handful
representative maybe some would be
Democrat but they're probably a
Republican here in their two-to-one
means six to six percent Democratic
which is overwhelming when you
consider how how close it is
particularly in the in the Senate all
right I got a run I appreciate the call
very much great to hear from you
interesting questions today we will take
calls again although not today apologies
to everybody I didn't get to hope you'll
call in again